all right I hope that you can hear me
now so sorry for that um so Elder ski is
at studied at Oak University and the
Theological Seminary at Andrews
University um where he received his
education for the
ministry now let
me okay
perfect so let me welcome Elder SK in
fact let
me give him oh there we go yes wonderful
thank you so much for joining us Elder
SK I'm sure you just finished speaking
yes yes literally thank you so much for
joining us uh to discuss the Divinity of
Christ we thank you for your time and
for giving us this opportunity to delve
into this vital truth that Jesus indeed
is Lord he is God so I will pass it over
to you Elder to share any opening
remarks before we get into the Q&A
session thank you very much my dear
sister God bless you all those listening
I am am very delighted to be a part of
this particular Q&A because it talks
about the Divinity of Jesus Christ and
the Divinity of Christ and the humanity
of Christ are absolutely essential
subject that is why I recommended that
we devote the entire hour only to the
Divinity of Christ and not to questions
unrelated that's how I uh view it to be
so important and so I pray that the
spirit of God will be with us that as we
discuss this absolutely essential
subject that those listening may be
enlightened and their faith might be
strengthened God glorified and the devil
disgraced amen amen amen all right so
let us get into our first question our
first question Elder ski is how do we
know or how did Jesus rather how did
Jesus manifest his
divinity let's pray first Father in
Heaven as we discuss this subject I ask
you in the name of Jesus Christ grant us
wisdom promised in James chapter 1
verse5 remember also the words of David
in Psalm 119 ver8 open thou mine eyes
open our eyes open our minds open our
understanding I pray in Jesus name
amen before we answer the question how
did Jesus demonstrate his divinity we
should first deal with how does the
bible present evidence that Jesus Christ
was
divine was Jesus Christ truly Divine is
he Divine and does the bible teach that
let us go to uh Hebrews chapter 1
Hebrews chap well let's go to John
chapter one we must establish his
divinity first that he was divine still
is always will be then we can answer the
question how did he demonstrate his
divinity in John chap 1 verse one the
Bible says in the beginning was the word
and the Word was with God and the Word
was God the same was in the beginning
with God all things were made by him and
without him was not anything made that
was made verse 11 he was in the world
verse 10 he was in the world and the
world was made by him and the world knew
him not so the Bible is very clear that
Jesus is the one who created heaven and
earth now the Hebrew word for create is
only applied to God but in addition to
that we have the evidence of God the
Father himself declaring Christ to be
the Creator and only only a Divine being
can create because creation is bringing
into existence that which had no prior
existence and bring it into existence
out of nothing now in Hebrews chapter 1
verse 10 God the father is addressing
the son and God the father says and thou
Lord in the beginning has laid the
foundations of the earth and the heavens
are the work of thy hands and so God the
Father ident ifies Jesus Christ as the
creator of Heaven and Earth in the book
of Hebrews still in chapter one reading
from verse one God who at sunry times
and in diverse manners spake in time
pass unto the fathers by the prophets ha
in these last days spoken unto us by his
son whom he hath appointed heir of All
Things by whom also he made the world
and so the Bible is very clear that
Christ was the agent of creation is he
that said let there be light let there
be a firmament let the Earth bring forth
grass Jesus Christ is the creator in
Psalm 90 verse1 Lord thou H has been our
Dwelling Place in all generations before
the mountains were brought forth orever
thou H has formed the earth and the
world even from Everlasting to
Everlasting Thou Art God we know it was
Christ who for the mountains the heavens
and the earth and the psalmist by the
way that was d uh Moses writing he says
he has been from Everlasting to
Everlasting that can only be applied to
God and so Jesus Christ is God Jesus
Christ is divine he is as Divine as the
father is and so we need to establish
that first now the question was how did
Jesus Christ demonstrate
his divinity let me say first that
Christ did not live his life by his own
divine power he lived his life depending
on the power of the father that was an
example to us because his Humanity was a
real humanity and Humanity must be lived
in a state of dependence let me say that
again human beings were made dependent
all of creation is dependent when Christ
took on human condition he took on
dependence and so in his own personal
life he depended on the power of the
father that's why he said I can my own
selves do nothing as I hear I Judge John
5 verse3 and 31
now Christ forgave sins he forgave the
woman who uh washed his feet with her
tears and dried them with her her hair
uh Luke chapter 7 verse
4748 only God can forgive sins Mark 25-7
and so by forgiving sins Jesus Christ
demonstrated his divinity by accepting
worship Jesus Christ demonstrated his
divinity he accepted worship he forgave
sins because even while he was human he
was still God and that's the great
mystery that's why we can never fully
understand either side of Christ the
Divinity or the humanity but we must
study them and so he demonstrated his
divinity primarily in forgiving sins and
in the fact that he accepted worship and
in the fact that he clearly stated on
more than one occasion that he was equal
with the father and the Jews understood
that because in John chapter 5 the Bible
says but Jesus said unto them my father
worketh hither to and I work Verse 18
therefore the Jews sought the more to
kill him because he not only had broken
the Sabbath but said also that God was
his father making himself equal with God
and so even if he had not forgiven sins
even if he had not um accepted worship
he made it clear I am equal with my
father and the Jews understood that was
what he was saying and that's why they
tried to kill him I didn't mean to go so
long but Christ demonstrated his
divinity by what he did and by what he
said he claimed to be equal with the
father and of course Jesus Christ never
lied amen amen
amen thank you for delving into that
Elder SK by first establishing that
Christ is indeed Divine because one he
accepted worship and he had the ability
to forgive sins
Jes and then he also manifested that
Divinity the life that he lived on lived
here on this Earth so now El theke now
that we know that Jesus indeed is God
and we have seen the manifestation of
his divinity through the life that he
lived what role now does Christ's
Divinity play in The Plan of Salvation
all
right if Jesus Christ is not God he
cannot save
you let me say that very very clearly if
Christ is not Divine let me put it this
way he cannot save
you let's uh grab your bibl sister
Denisha and go to Daniel chapter 10 now
the angel Gabriel is talking to Daniel
here is what he tells Daniel Daniel had
been praying 3 weeks he wants to
understand certain aspects of Prophecy
when would the 70 weeks conclude so that
the Israelites or the Jews might return
to Jerusalem and the angel Gabriel who
had been ordered by God to help Daniel
understand all that God told him he
comes to Daniel and he explains why
there was a delay in the answer this
prayer Now read from verse 12 of Daniel
10 or anyone else who's listening who
wants to read Daniel 10 reading from
verse 12 read that for us then said he
unto me fear not Daniel for from the
first day that thou did set thine heart
to understand yes and to chasten thyself
before thy God thy words were heard and
I am come for thy words keep reading
keep reading verse 13 yes but the prince
of the kingdom of Persia yes with stod
me one and 20 days pause pause pause the
the the prince of the kingdom of Persia
is merely a title applied to Satan the
prince of the kingdom of Persia is a
title apply because Prince then means
ruler not necessarily someone less than
a king but a ruler Christ is called the
prince he's a ruler the prince of the
kingdom of Persia With stod Me Now who
is me that's Gabriel Gabriel is the
highest angel in heaven after Lucifer
fell El white writes in desar of Ages P
693 paragraph 3 The Mighty Angel who
stands in God's presence occupying the
position from which Lucifer fell came to
the sight of Christ of course that's in
the Garden of Gethsemane Desire of Ages
P 693 paragraph 3 we are talking about
the highest angel in heaven but he said
the prince of the kingdom of Persia a
title referring to Satan with stod me
some Power withstood the highest Angel
for 21 days now keep reading that verse
13 but low
yes Michael uhhuh one of the chief
princes or it could be read the first
prince came to help me and I remained
there with the kings of Persia Gabriel
had to call Christ to help him because
Gabriel you see Gabriel and Satan were
both contending for the mind of the
Persian king whether to let the
Israelites go or not the Jews go or not
Gabriel could not get through this is
the highest angel in heaven he was
opposed by satanic power Jesus Christ
came and he was the one who assisted
Gabriel finally Gabriel succeeded what
I'm trying to tell you is that the
highest angel in heaven is no match
oneon-one of himself with Satan I'm not
glorifying Satan I simply want our
listeners to understand that when Satan
was thrown out of Heaven he lost his
position he did not lose his power only
divine power can conquer
Satan are you with me only divine power
can conquer Satan El white writes in
testimonies Volume 5 page 448 paragraph
2 Christ can limit the power of Satan in
evangelism page 617 paragraph 2 the
prince of the power and evil can only be
held in check by the power of God the
power of God in the third person of the
godhead the Holy Spirit and I believe as
testimony volume 1 P 34 one paragraph
one God Alone can limit the power of
Satan and so she identifies God she
identifies Christ she identifies the
Holy Spirit as the only persons who can
limit the power of
Satan only a Divine being can overcome
the power of Satan and so if Jesus
Christ is not Divine he cannot be a
savior because sin is the power of sin
is the power of Satan as verily as the
power of righteousness is the power of
the very life of God the very Life of
Christ and so the fact that Gabriel the
highest angel in heaven needed Christ to
come and help him tells us clearly that
he needed the help of a superior power
and that power was divine being Jesus
Christ whom the Bible calls sometimes
Michael Jesus Christ is very God Jesus
Christ is the mighty Jehovah now go to
Isaiah chapter 9 Isaiah chapter 9 verse
is that where we're going absolutely Dr
Denisha verse 6 yes indeed read that for
us the word of us yes for unto us a
child is born that's Humanity that's
Humanity go on unto us a son is given
that's humanity and the government shall
be upon his
shoulder and his name Shall be Called
wonderful counselor yes the Mighty God
pause the Mighty God the Mighty God of
the Bible is Jesus Christ let me say
that again go to Isaiah chapter
41 and we cannot say too much about the
Divinity of Jesus Christ Isaiah chapter
41 read verse
4 who hath wrought and done it calling
the generations from the beginning from
the beginning yes I the Lord the Lord
the first the first uhhuh and with the
last the last I am I am he now so we
have the first and the last he's
identifying himself as the first and the
last now go to Revelation chapter
22 revelation 22 read verse
13 I am
Alpha Oma uhhuh the beginning uhhuh and
the end uhhuh the first first and the
last now we know that's Jesus Christ
because the revelation of Jesus Christ
which God gave to him and he gave it to
the angel the angel to John John to the
churches and so the Revelation tells us
that the beginning and the end the Alpha
and the Omega that is Jesus Christ
identified in Isaiah 41 verse4 now go to
Isaiah 42 and read verse 5
thus sayith the Lord excuse me thus
sayith God the Lord yes he that created
the heavens and stretched them out now
we know that is Christ we know that is
Christ and he's called thus sayith God
the Lord that is Jesus Christ now go to
Isaiah
43 and I want to give biblical evidence
upon biblical evidence there must be no
doubt about the Divinity of Jesus Christ
Isaiah 43 read verse three
for I am the Lord thy God the Holy One
of Israel uhhuh thy savior pause wait a
minute who is our savior Jesus it's
Jesus Christ Matthew 1 verse 211 and she
shall bring forth a son and thou shalt
call his name Jesus why for he shall
save his people from their sins the
savior is Christ and he's identified in
Isaiah 43:3 as the savior read verse 11
of Isaiah
43 sorry I was flipping over to Matthew
Isaiah
43:1 I even I am the Lord and beside me
there is no
savior now there's there's none other
name under Heaven given among men
whereby we must be saved and that name
is Jesus and he is a savior you call him
Jesus why he shall save his people from
their sins beside neither is no other
savior who is that speaking in Isaiah
43:11 that's Jesus Christ Christ is
divine read verse 14 of Isaiah
43 thus sayth the Lord your Redeemer the
Holy One of Israel yeah he's the
Redeemer who is the Redeemer it is
Jehovah God it is Jesus Christ Jesus is
the mighty god of the Old Testament he's
the God man of the New Testament he's
the God man now in the most holy Place
Jesus Christ is divine now let's add to
that let us go to John Chapter
2 we read from verse 19 of John Chapter
2 Jesus before you read let's pray again
father we're dealing with an absolutely
essential subject give us wisdom de God
in Jesus name I pray amen John chapter 2
verse 19 Jesus answered and said unto
them destroy this temple in three days
and in three days I will raise it up now
I always urge people to read the Bible
microscopically the text says destroy
this Temple and in three days who would
raise it up I will raise it that's what
Jesus says Now read verse 20
then said the Jews 46 years was this
temple in building building and wil thou
it up in days days they did not
understand even the disciples never
understood what Jesus said he listened
to Christ explaining keep reading oh
listen to the explanation verse 21 but
he spake of the temple the Temple of his
body his body now what was he saying in
verse 19 if I die I Will Raise Myself
are you following me now only God can do
that now let's go to John chapter 10
John chapter
10 yes let's read from verse
16 other sheep I have in which are not
of this fold of this fold uhhuh them
also I must bring and they shall hear my
voice
and there shall be one fold and one
Shepherd keep
reading therefore doth my father love me
because I laay down my life that I might
take it again now Verse 18 very
carefully no man taketh it from me but I
lay it down of
myself I have power to lay it down and I
have power to take it again this
commandment have I received of my father
what is Jesus Christ say I will lay down
my life for you he didn't say I'll be
killed I will although the Bible talks
about he go to Jerusalem and be killed
but Christ actually laid down his life
for us he gave it up then he took it up
now when he says in verse 18 this
commandment have I received of my father
the father told him when to get up are
you following me that is why frequently
the Bible says the father raised him the
father raised him because he came up at
the command of the father but he raised
himself it's very important that we
understand that if someone else had
raised Jesus it would not have been
Jesus conquering death it would have
been someone else conquering death Jesus
conquered death by raising himself from
the dead and there was nothing the devil
could do but he came up at the command
of the father told him when to come up
the father told him when to Die the
father told Jesus when to do whatever he
did but it was he by the power the life
that was in him he raised himself from
the
dead because our greatest enemy is death
and The Last Enemy that shall be
destroyed is death Jesus Took on our
greatest enemy our greatest enemy is not
really Satan because Satan has no power
over US unless we give it to him our
enemy at one level is ourselves but the
other enemy is death and the Bible says
The Last Enemy that shall be destroyed
is death death and hell will be cast
into the Lake of Fire Jesus Christ he
went volun voluntarily into death he
didn't have to be chased he went into
death then he brought himself out and by
that he tells us among other things I
can deliver you from any circumstance
because the most irreversible
circumstance for a human being is death
if I get sick I can reverse it with
medication exercise change of diet and
lifestyle if I lose money I can get it
back if I lose a spouse I can get her
back we can get a lot of things back if
I die I cannot get my life back someone
has to raise me Jesus raised himself and
by the power that was in him and he
tells you in me I can raise you up by
the very same let let the Bible show
that to us go to Ephesians 1 quickly my
dear doctor Ephesians 1 let's read from
verse 19 it's a remarkable teaching it's
based on the Divinity of Jesus Christ
Ephesians 1 let's read from verse 19 and
what is the exceeding greatness of his
power to us word Paul's right there the
exceeding Paul wants us to understand
what great power God makes available to
us you see what is the exceeding
greatness of his power to us who believe
keep reading according to the working of
his mighty powery power which he wrought
in Christ when he raised him from the
dead so here we have a verse saying the
father raised him but we know from John
10:18 the Christ came up at the command
of the father what the verse is saying
the same Power by which Christ came from
the dead is the same power God makes
available to us to live lives of victory
over the death of sin and so a Divine
being raised him by by divine power he
raised himself from the dead and he
makes that same death cancelling power
available to us the biggest problem I
face is not debt it is not sickness the
most irreversible problem I face is
Death Christ says I have the power to
deliver you from death because I
delivered myself only by his divine
power could Christ reverse death conquer
death and back from the grave and he
came back from the second death by the
way not the death you and I people die
from day to day from the second death
all
right wow next question powerful all
right so we have established the
Divinity of Christ and we have also
understood that in order for Christ to
Deliver Us From The Bondage of death he
had to have been Divine and we see yes
course of course now we're asking
another question Jesus being Divine
before we ask that question yes let us
go back let's go to Hebrews 2 let's do
some reasoning in the scriptures and
strengthen our mind Hebrews
2 Hebrews
2 let's read verse 14 and verse 15 okay
for as much then as the children are
partakers of Flesh and Blood he also
himself likewise took part of the same
yes that through death he might destroy
him that that had the power of death now
that's the devil he might destroy him
that had the power of death but the
power of the devil can only be conquered
by the power of God are you following me
yes and so it was divine power that
conquered the person who had the power
of
death that's the power of Christ which
is no different from the power of God
which is no different from the power of
the Holy Spirit divine power through
death he might destroy him that had the
power of death and how did Christ do by
coming back from the dead and making
that death cancelling power available to
us all right go on uh Dr Denisha go
ahead
now that is the
devil and deliver them who through fear
of death all their lifetime subject to
to bondage there is nothing we fear more
than death and Christ delivers us from
that fear by showing us what he did to
death he canceled it he reversed it he
came back from it there's no need for
you to be afraid of death because to be
afraid of death is to be afraid of Satan
and there's no need for that look at
meus Christ I am life and all life
originates with the Divine being and
that's God himself all right next
question amen this next question Elder
ski is did Christ have the capacity or
the ability to
sin the answer is yes and the devil knew
that always keep in mind that Satan knew
Christ very well he knew him he was the
closest person to Christ ELO white
writes in the faith I live by Page 66
paragraph 2 I believe it is speaking of
Satan God made him good and beautiful as
near as possible like himself who is
this God it was Jesus Christ Christ
deliberately and intentionally and
consciously created Lucifer as much like
himself as possible no one else looked
more like Christ than Lucifer are you
following me Lucifer knew Christ when
Christ came to this earth Lucifer knew
who he was and he knew that Christ could
sin that's why he tempted Christ
remember that Lucifer was the smartest
person that Christ ever made the
smartest being ever created he did not
lose that he knew that Christ could have
sin that's why he went after Christ yes
Jesus Christ had the potential because
he took human nature to sin he chose not
to sin and that's an example for you and
for me you and I can choose not to sin
we choose not to sin by the power of
Christ we choose to sin by our own power
our own sinful nature but to choose not
to sin requires the power of Christ
which is the power of God when I say to
choose not to sin you and I can choose
not to do that sin or this sin but to
choose to resist the principle of sin
requires the the power of Christ and
that must be a divine power Jesus Christ
could have sinned that is why the devil
tempted him but he trusted the word of
God and by total trust in his father's
word and the word of God is as powerful
as God himself Jesus Christ resisted and
conquered and lived a Victorious Life
the the victory Christ won is a victory
available to us because he came in our
condition we cannot make Christ less
human because then we cannot connect
with him Hebrews 1 tells us he is fully
Divine Hebrews 2 tells us he's fully
human
amen we have not an high priest which
cannot be tempted with a feeling of our
infirmities but was in all points
tempted like as we are he feels what we
feel the humanity of Christ which we'll
deal in our next program a month from
now is as essential as a Divinity of
Christ when you pray in the Name of
Christ you're pray in the name of
someone who has the power to do
something about your human problem which
he understands because he was human so
we have not an high priest which cannot
be touched with the feeling of our
infirmities our weaknesses of the flesh
or in all points tempted like as we are
okay next question by the way El says
when discussing that subject taking
shoes off your feet but we'll deal with
the humanity of Christ a few weeks from
now next question on the divinity
amen amen well our next question well
our next two questions will be asked by
sister Chelsea Jack all right um Chelsea
are you ready to ask the next
questions yes I am I'm just have trying
to start my camera start my video but
it's not working oh
sorry but I can hear you camera or not I
can hear
you okay all right well um it is nice to
be having this conversation because I
feel like something that the church is
struggling with or some people in the
church is reverence and it is so
important to reverence
God when we learn about his divinity it
automatically just raises and we think
of reverence as something that's scary
or at least I did I'm like o I have to
reverence God but reverence is literally
just being in awe of in a of okay okay
yes so and also you just talking about
how
you know heaven was
bankrupt and you know they sent Jesus
down on the off chance not even the off
chance but they it was a possibility as
you said might sin because could have
and that's so amazing and you know it
just speaks of the love of God yes the
love of God
indeed the first question is well the
fourth question what is the role of
Christ now now the role of Christ
now Christ is our high Priestly
intercessor in a Most Holy place if you
study the sanctuary Services the day of
atonement took place on the 10th day of
the seventh month this was fulfilled
October 22844 when Christ moved into the
second compartment he is our intercessor
standing on the right hand of the father
interceding for those who have given
their lives to him completely he is uh
in the process of cleansing the
sanctuary from sin but to cleanse that
Century he has to cleanse this Century
because the uncleanness of that century
is the result of what we send up through
confession and repentance and so Christ
is our intercessor he is a very solemn
uh activity he is examining along with
the Father the names in The Book of Life
which Nam should remain which name
should be removed and that decision is
based really on whether not ref fful to
Christ or not it is not an arbitrary
decision God makes to take a name out of
The Book of Life God told Moses he that
have sinned against me him will I take
out of my book and so when Christ is
right now determining who will be his
and who is not whose confession of faith
is genuine whose confession is not
merely lip service so this is the work
that's going on now but for anyone whose
life is given to Christ that person need
not worry because the life given to
Christ cannot be lost and so the issue
is is my life fully surrendered to
Christ that he might be my advocate in
my favor and not against me that he
might say Come Ye blessed of my father
and not depart from me the work of
Christ now is simply a work of
intercession a work of determining who
is his and who is not based by our own
choices let me say that again based on
our own choices John 3:19 this is the
condemnation that light is coming into
the world and Men love Darkness rather
than light because the days were evil
John 5:40 I think it is and he will not
come to me that he might have life and
so the work in Heaven Is God
acknowledging uh the choices we have
made and Christ speaking for us if our
lives are fully surrendered to him it is
the most solemn work going on right now
my dear sister and all my listening
friends it is a judgment that's been
going on in heaven right now when that
is finished that's when Jesus Christ
takes off his PRI robes put on his
kingly robes takes off the miter puts on
the kingly crown and he comes back for
those who are truly his and to get rid
of those who are his enemies Christ
right now is an
intercessor anyone whose life is given
to Christ you've got Christ on your side
and so the issue is is my life in the
hands of
Christ and only a Divine being can
intercede the way Christ is interceding
and his intercession is based on his
sacrifice I came to this earth lived a
difficult life conquered sin laid down
my life came back from Death on the
basis of all of that I can intercede for
you no angel can do that only Divine
being can do that only Divine being can
give eternal
life and Christ gives
it next
question before we move on I just want
to remind us of how even on Earth Jesus
out the road map or he showed us how he
would intercede he was interceding in
the garden of Geth Gethsemane for his
disciples did on Earth he would spend
all night in that Garden you know pray
for them even now Jesus is saying father
remember my sacrifice and it's just it's
amazing and the next question is what is
the impact of Jesus's Divinity in our
lives the impact of Christ in our lives
it is by the power of Christ the divine
power that you and I are made Godly or
Godlike in order to reach a Divine
standard you need divine power and that
power is the very Life of Christ not
just the human life of Christ the Divine
Life of Christ Christ lived the perfect
life by the divine power of his father
we can live a Victorious Life by the
divine power of Christ because because
the life required of us is no different
from the life Jesus lived on this Earth
in our Human Condition let me say that
again the life required of you and me is
no different from the life Christ lived
when he was on this Earth and so the
Divinity of Christ is the power whereby
you and I can reach that standard as
elte writes in a um education page 18
paragraph 4 higher than the highest
human thought can reach is God's ideal
for his children
godliness godlikeness is the goal to be
reached remember God said let us make
man in our image it was always God's
desire that his creation Adam and Eve
and The Descendants would be like God
not be God but be like God as much as
possible in conflict and courage page 21
paragraph 5 G writes God created man for
his own Glory that after test and trial
the Human family might become one with
the Heavenly family this is astonishing
God's ultimate aim was to unite his
creation Humanity with himself and that
is still his desire it is astonishing to
think that God will blend Humanity with
divinity the power to live that kind of
life is the power of Christ because the
power of Christ is the only Power that
can conquer Satan and Satan is our
constant adversary our constant enemy
the lion seeking to destroy us and so
the Divinity of Christ gives me Comfort
that I can conquer any weakness in my
life or it can be conquered by the power
of Christ it isn't I That Conquers it it
is Christ conquering in me as I
surrender to him without the Divinity of
Christ there is no hope of Conquest over
sin none you may live decent life you
cannot live a Victorious Life over
sin amen thank you thank you for that
and also to add on Christ's power and
His Majesty we know that light is
stronger than Darkness we know that God
you know the enemy is no match for God
and when on God's side we can even have
comfort in walking the streets and
knowing that his angels and His holy
spirit is with us so if the enemy tries
anything like God said like the Bible
says there was a hedge of protection
around around job yes enemy tried every
way to get in and he could not have so
that's another way that the Divinity of
Christ the power of Christ can comfort
as as Christians we don't have to walk
the streets scared of Co or scared of
this or scared of that like
unbelievers we can have faith in the
power of Christ in our lives so thank
you and that was the last question and
that Faith must be operationalized
through obedience let me say it again
that Faith must have legs and the legs
are plain and simple obedience to thus
said the Lord yes amen
God bless you my dear sister thank you I
will turn it back over to Denisha all
right thank you it's 2:45 1:45 in
Houston where I am
now yes yes in fact I just want to let
everyone know thank God Elder ski is
joining us all the way from Houston
Texas on two assignments yes I am took
the time to be here with us he's
actually an hour ahead of us here behind
an behind yes thank you an hour behind
us in uh those of us in New York so I
know it's right after Divine service you
quickly found a room probably in the
church to do this live stream so thank
you all this we have thank you we have
actually completed the you know
questions per say on the Divinity of
Christ that we have written up is there
anyone on this line right now who has a
question
pertaining amen pertaining to the
Divinity of Christ that you would like
to ask if you are here on if you are
here on Zoom you can use the raise your
hand feature and I will unmute you and
allow you to ask your
question all
right brother
Kelly you can unmute and ask your
question okay happy Sabbath
everyone my question is I know you said
pastor risi that uh uh is is the way how
we you know you have to surrender your
life to Christ right to experence that
Divinity of God in your life so how can
one surrender fully to God like how can
you like just give him full control of
every aspect in your life so you can you
know live that's that's the next
question it really is let's go to the
Book of John Chapter 2 John chapter 2
John Chapter 2 this is Christ performing
the very first miracle changing water
into wine we'll read that story we read
from verse three to verse five to answer
my brother's question how do I make that
surrender all right the word of the Lord
says and father please just continue to
guide and direct this as we answer this
question of how can we fully surrender
everything to you make your word plain
to us in Jesus's name amen amen amen
thank you my good sister ah my pleasure
okay John 2:3 M and when they wanted
wine the mother of Jesus saith unto him
they have no wine verse four Jesus saith
unto
Heroman what have I to do with thee mine
hour is not yet come uhhuh his mother
saith unto him excuse me the servants M
listen carefully whatsoever he saith
unto you do it and now this is how we
surrender entirely to Christ we are
willing to do whatever Jesus tells us to
do this is the total surrender to Christ
let's go to Genesis chapter 41 look at a
man who symbolized Jesus Christ and
we'll see a similar situation Genesis 41
read verse 55 Genesis
41:55 discussing the Divinity of
Christ and when all the land of Egypt
was famished uhhuh the people cried to
Pharaoh for bread stop now remember God
gave Pharaoh two dreams and each dream
taught there would be seven years of
plenty and seven years of famine no one
could explain except Joseph years later
no one can explain except Daniel when
the seven years of famine came famine
produces death famine is absence of food
now the famine has come the people are
facing death they want to live now in
that context read verse 55 again and
when all the land of Egypt was
famished the people cried to Pharaoh for
bread and Pharaoh said unto all the
Egyptians go unto Joseph that's right
and what he sath unto you that's right
do if you want what if you want to live
whatever Joseph tells you do that now
Joseph represents Jesus
Christ Jesus Christ his mother said look
you do whatever he tells you to
do I don't want to sound worked up but I
am a total surrender to Christ is simply
a willingness to do whatever he tells
you to do without discussion and
recommendations and advice to God this
is how we surrender entirely to Christ
what will thou have me to do that's what
Paul said on the road to Damascus and
Paul did exactly what Jesus Christ said
total surrender is a willingness to say
Lord I am ready to do whatever you want
and to find out what he wants you've got
to go to the word of God that's a good
question from my dear brother God bless
him so obey God in your diet obey God in
your dress obey God in your work obey
God in every aspect of your life this is
total
surrender amen amen obedience obey God
in your romantic Behavior obey God in
every single thing this is because if
you reserve one area for you that God
doesn't control that area is controlled
by the devil not by you by the devil it
is God in total control or God not at
all Jesus told that scribe in Mark chap
12 Thou shalt love the Lord thy God with
all thy heart with all thy soul with all
thy mind with all thy strength that's to
will surrender that's how we surrender
No Reservations
whatsoever amen amen thank you a partial
surrender to God is
useless e is completely or you're
not amen amen all right Elder ski our
next question comes from sister Chelsea
Jack she wants you to elaborate on how
Jesus died the second
death mentioned that before she says is
this referring to when it said that
Jesus went to hell and took the
keys now the B go to Revelation Chapter
2 let's read verse 10 of Revelation
2 fear none of those things which Thou
shalt suffer behold the devil shall cast
some of you into prison that ye may be
tried and ye shall have tribulation 10
days be thou faithful unto death and I
will give thee a Crown of Life Next
verse he that hath an heir let him hear
what the spirit saith unto the
churches he that overcometh shall not
not be hurt hurt of the second death now
the says the wages of sin is death now
that's the second death for which you
can't come back Lazarus died but came
back what he died initially was not the
second death that's not the punishment
for sin that's a consequence you know
good Abraham died but that's not the
second death the second death is that
from which no one returns that's why the
Bible says he that overcometh shall not
be hurt of the second death let's go to
Revelation chapter 2
from verse one Revelation not chapter 2
sorry chapter 20 of Revelation chapter
20 let's read verse
14 and death and hell were cast into the
Lake of Fire this is the second death
This is the end of everything there is
no return everything tainted by sin
large degree small degree is absolute
wiped out finally along with the devil
sin hell hell death the grave everything
finally destroyed this is the second
death a permanent solution a permanent
end there is no possibility of return
this is what Jesus suffered for us it's
a mystery and he came back from
it he came back from
that that you and I do not have to
suffer
it Christ died he paid the wages of sin
not the consequences of sin he paid the
wages of sin and the wages of sin is
that from which a a child of God will
never suffer that's why Revelation 2:11
says he that overcometh shall not be
hurt of the second death Jesus took that
on for us so we do not have to suffer it
it was the second death Jesus died from
which no one comes back yet he came back
to administer to us the benefits of his
sacrifice he had to come back because a
dead Jesus couldn't save you but he came
back having tasted that death go to
Hebrews chapter 2 let's read verse 9
Hebrews 2
ver9 but we see Jesus who was made a
little lower than the
angels for the suffering of death
crowned with Glory and Honor that he by
the grace of God should taste death for
every man this was the second death that
Christ took on so anyone who comes to
him is covered because he's already
suffered that for you anyone now those
who are lost they will experience that
death in when they're destroyed in the
flames of fire they will experience what
Christ went through in the garden of 78
when he bled through his skin when all
the forces of Darkness were around him
they will experience what he felt on the
cross when the father forsook him the
sinner who is lost will experience that
for himself those of us who remain
faithful we're covered by the fact that
Christ took it on for
us amen amen amen thank you all anything
else okay yes sister Chelsea said she
understands now and now I have a greater
understanding well God bless
herela amen I will now um allow brother
Sherlock Cromwell to ask his question on
all right
Sherlock hello Elder hello everyone um
brother um yes many years ago you you
were the main guest of speaker at
Northeastern conference and you preached
a sermon I think it's wrong have to do
regarding the Divinity of Christ and I
think everyone need to hear that sermon
but I've been looking for it and I'm
unable to located do you know where I
can no sorry Dr Sherlock I have no clue
I think this question was who has your
back I think that was the sermon uh at a
camp meeting I think it was I don't know
my dear brother I'm so sorry I don't
know perhaps if you contact the
conference they may have it but I don't
know I really don't sorry thousand
pardons I don't know I don't know you
can take a chance and go on YouTube and
type in uh who has your back Randy SK it
may come up to your surprise who has
your back I think that was the title who
has your back okay thank you you're
welcome God bless you in your
family amen amen thank you brother sh
Sherlock
now uh brother Nick had a question I
didn't get to read the passage but he
says my question is Proverbs 8:
22-2 and I'm G to see if I can quickly
flip there Proverbs 8:
22-2 the word of the Lord says the Lord
possess me in the beginning of his way
before his works of old I was set up
from Everlasting from the beginning
whever the Earth was when there were no
depths I was brought forth when there
were no fountains abounding with water
before the mountains were settled before
the hills was I brought forth and his
question is what does it mean that Jesus
was
born was
born yes what do you mean Jesus was born
what what does it mean that Jesus was
born yes that's yes but Christ came into
this earth now the birth of Christ is a
tremendous mystery because a physical
man was not involved are you following
me Christ was Christ came into a woman
into her womb it was the work of the
Holy Spirit to place that Holy thing the
Bible calls it in the womb of Mary we
cannot explain all any of the details as
to how that occurred it was the might
the angel told Mary the Holy Spirit
shall come upon you and the power of the
mighty shall overshadow you and that
Holy thing which shall be born of they
shall be called uh the Son of God so
that's all we can say it was a a Divine
miracle that allowed the Mighty God to
be placed in human form in the womb of a
woman but before Christ came in human
form he always existed let no one get
you to believe that at some point in the
dark and distant eternity Christ came
forth Christ has always existed because
the Bible is very clear in Colossians
1:16 and he uh verse 17 he is before all
things by him all things consist for by
him verse 16 were all things created
look at all things it occurs four times
in those two verses for by him were all
things created that are in heaven that
are in Earth which means everywhere
where visible and invisible whether they
be Thrones or dominions or
principalities or Powers all things were
created by Him and He is before all
things and by him all things why does
the Holy Spirit move Paul to write all
things nothing existed except it existed
by the work of Jesus Christ so he had to
have been there all the time never
surrender to the deception that Jesus
Christ had a beginning his Humanity had
a beginning his divinity had none a God
cannot have a beginning because then who
began him if God had a beginning whoever
began him is greater than he is God
Divinity does not have a beginning
according to Bible teaching Jesus Christ
before he took on Humanity always
existed and this was such a tremendous
concept for the Bible writers all they
could say is from Everlasting to
Everlasting for instance uh Psalm 90
which we read earlier Lord thou Hast
been our Dwelling Place in all
generations before the mountains are
brought forth orever thou has formed the
earth and the world thus as far back as
they can go you see from Everlasting to
ever now how long is one Everlasting you
tell me now we have two the writer is
trying to tell us that the creator has
always been there never ever be seduced
by the teaching that the pre-incarnate
Christ Christ before he became human had
a beginning God cannot have a beginning
God has always been there Genesis 1:1 in
the beginning God created the Heaven and
the Earth Heaven is space the beginning
is time the Earth is matter God had to
exist before time before space before
matter in order to create them Jesus
Christ is a Creator he has always been
there I here to be so forceful but this
is too significant for anyone to leave
this program believing that Jesus had a
beginning before he became human Christ
always existed Hebrews chapter 1 reading
from verse 10 and thou Lord in the
beginning has laid the foundation of the
earth and the heavens are the heaven are
the work of thy hands they Shall Perish
but thou remainest and they all shall
wax all as of a garment and as a vest sh
thou fold them up and they shall be
changed but Thou Art the same and thy
years shall not fail the father is
saying the son is eternal and if the
father says that who am I to question
that Jesus Christ has always existed he
came as a human being he had a beginning
as a human being But as God he has
always existed
amen amen thank you thank you so much
someone who is not Eternal cannot give
you eternal life because he's giving you
something he doesn't have let me say
that again Christ gives us eternal life
where did he get it because he is
eternal an angel cannot give eternal
life because he's not Eternal Jesus
Christ is eternal that's why he can give
eternal
life do not be confused Jesus Christ had
no
beginning as a Divine being he has
always existed now that boggles the mind
when you and I get to heaven he will
explain to us more and
more amen all right next question before
I get more work what's the next question
well I'm going to unmute uh Prince Eli
to ask his question about the Divinity
of all right we have a prince okay yes
yeah yes Prince good evening from Ghana
how are you I'm very friend in you ah no
complaints at all God is good yeah
I I'll be waiting for you in Ghana in
from May 11 oh okay God bless you my
question my question is based on the
surrender you just explain right now are
you saying surrender to Christ you don't
have to make mistakes no no I'm not
saying that I'm not saying that you see
go uh Denisha go to First Peter chapter
one brother Prince that's a very good
question and I hope the answer will give
comfort and encouragement to those who
are listening First Peter chapter 1
let's read verse
two all right 1 Peter chap 1 verse 2 the
Bible pray first pray first let's ask
for more wisdom dear Lord as we read
your word we ask for more wisdom in fact
James 1 I believe verse eight tells us
that if we lack wisdom that we can ask
you you do not upgrade but you give
liberally so please liberally shower us
with your wisdom in Jesus's name we pray
amen that's James 15 oh5 thank you yes
15 yes
okay so you said 1 Peter chapter 1
verse2 Elder chapter 2 verse two ah
first first Peter 2 verse two okay got
it thank you as newborn babes yes desire
the sincere milk of the word uhhuh that
he may grow grow thereby Christian
experience is a growing experience but
there's a difference you see you grow
while you're surrendered to Christ
you're growing when you make a mistake
you're covered by Christ and so 1 John
CH 2:1 said little children these things
right you that you sin not and if any
man sin be have Advocate with a father
yes you can make a mistake brother
Prince but you don't make a conscious
decision to make a mistake that's not
the way we make
mistakes deliberate sin is not to
distinguish the life of the believer we
accidentally make a mistake even when we
do do it deliberately we confess it
immediately yes the child of God will
make mistakes but will confess them and
the child of God will not be glad to
make mistakes he or she will be sorry we
make mistakes are you with me but we
have a power the power of forgiveness
from God but we're still God's children
but he requires us to confess repent so
you will make mistakes because you're
learning to be Godly by the power of
Christ brother the prince don't go don't
be happy that you'll make mistakes you
see what I'm trying to say let's try to
avoid mistakes but when we make them
there's power from Christ to forgive to
strengthen us to lift us up that we may
continue
walking the only person in the Bible who
never made a mistake was Jesus Christ or
should I say who never made a sin was
Jesus Christ Abraham made mistakes Enoch
made them Paul made them you know Seth
made them methusa made them Elijah
Elisha they all and the Bible has a
record of the sins and mistakes of God's
people because God does not want to pull
the wool over our eyes people make
mistakes but there's forgiveness that
thou mayest be feared as we told in
Psalm 13 verse four I believe it is all
right thank you brother Prince God bless
you amen amen sorry sorry my bad my
bad all right so I'll make this the last
question Elder ski okay okay this is
from eileene
Skinner please repeat the explanation of
God telling Jesus when to get up from
the dead or to go
down all right let's go to
um John 10 John
okay let's read Verse
again no man taketh it from me Jesus
talking but I lay it down of
myself I have power to lay it down and I
have power to take it again uhhuh this
commandment uhhuh have I received of my
father now the father told Jesus when to
lay his life down when to take it up
always remember the Life of Christ is
our example Jesus only did what the
father told him to do he only said what
the father told him to say
now remember there were there was an
angel go to Matthew 28 Matthew 28 let's
read from verse two of M well let's read
from verse one of Matthew
28 verse one Matthew 28 let's
read in the end of the
Sabbath as it began began to Dawn Dawn
toward the first day of the week Came
Mary Magdalene Magdalene and the other
Mary Mary to see the soker uhhuh all
right go on and behold there was a great
earthquake for the angel of the Lord
descended from heaven and came and
rolled back the Stone from the door and
sat upon it yes his countenance was like
lightning and his reignment white as
snow uhhuh and for fair of him the
keepers did Shake
became men
here's the scenario an angel comes down
from heaven the angel of the Lord by the
way sometimes the expression Angel of
the Lord refers to Christ clearly it is
not referred to Christ on this occasion
because Christ is in the Tomb the angel
rolls the stone back in preparation for
what the resurrection of Jesus the
resurrection now ELO tells us in Des of
Ages the angel to came to tell Christ
your father is calling you and then
Christ came up and so the father sent an
angel God does things in ways we can
understand to tell Christ time to get up
and Christ Rose by the life that was in
him now keep in mind when Jesus raised
Lazarus somehow Lazarus responded this
dead Lazarus responded to the lifegiving
words of Jesus Christ there was a
response from Lazarus now Lazarus didn't
raise himself let me make that very
clear no dead person raises himself
Jesus Christ who was God and man raised
himself because while the human Christ
died the Divine side did not die
Divinity cannot die and so Christ with
the life that is his he raised himself
but the angel came to say your father's
calling you and he raised himself by the
command of the father but with the power
that he had in him the the human was
dead but the Divine cannot die
mysterious in many ways but there's not
in the Bible for us to believe that
Jesus raised himself at the command of
the father because Jesus never said
anything or did anything without the
permission of the father it's an amazing
way to live by the way that's how you
and I should
live if we live that way we'd avoid a
lot of
problems a lot of problems if not
all all right amen well Elder SK I
wanted to make that the last question
now keep my word brother
and uh man example God willing we will
ask your questions next month because I
have another assignment right away so I
have to run away there we go Elder thank
you so much for your time you're welcome
spirit of God continue to fall aresh on
you and may you continue to radiate the
glory of the Lord God bless you thank
you so much and God bless you my dear
sister God bless all your listeners and
God bless this ministry that he's given
to you it is a blessing to many people
and I always talk of you when I talk to
you to people about young people this
young doctor in New York who loves God
and wants the truth to be spread all
over the world may the Lord bless you
bless your family and bless all those
who listened and may we fall in love
with Jesus more and more day by day and
to fall in love with Christ is to fall
in love with his word God bless you now
run away now amen thank you so much
Elder for that blessing be well
okay all right everyone thank you you
for participating in the Q&A segment of
our session on the Divinity of Christ
and I pray that you were blessed that we
are affirmed and we have the assurance
that Jesus indeed is God and His being
God allows us the opportunity to
overcome death in fact we will not taste
the second death and we have the
opportunity to live above sin and if we
do fall if we do make mistakes akes we
have an advocate with the father Jesus
Christ our high
priest um so I will now share this video
this piece of music it is God and God
Alone brother Jonathan produced it we
recorded this song and I pray it is an
encouragement for us and an admonition
that whatever we do whatever we own
belongs to God we spoke about total
surrender to God being uh marked by our
our obedience to him
may we keep God and God alone at the
center of our attention be blessed
[Music]
God created
all these things we
call from the mighty to the small
the glory in them
all is
God and God
Alone
Alone rals the
truth of all we call
know and the best and worst of men won't
ever change the master
plan it's
God and God
alone
[Music]
oh God the Lord
is fit to
take the
universe's
Throne let
everything that
lives reserve it true with
praise for
God and
God hello
[Music]
and God
Alone will be the
joy of our
Eternal
home he he will be our one desire and
our hearts will never TI
of
God and God the
Lord oh
God and God of
love it's F to
take the
universe's
Throne let
everything that Liv
reserve it true with
praise for
God and
God
[Music]
Alone God
Al it's F to
take the universe
let
everything that
lives preserve it true with
praise for
God
God let
everything that lives we serve it true
us
oh
God than
[Music]
God and amen for God and God alone I
will now allow sister Carla Hew to come
and do our
closing
prayer amen
amen let's bow our
heads thank you Lord for another Sabbath
and thank you that we're able to
actually meet unmolested and have the
studies that took place and that have
been taking place over the last few
months that allow us to be better
children of God um thank you so much for
those who put this program together and
allow the Holy Spirit to use them
overall um we ask for a special blessing
over both Pastor ski and Denisha because
I'm pretty sure the devil is upset with
them for always sharing truths with us I
ask that you allow us this upcoming week
to take in everything that was presented
to us and that we practice what we
preach as well and it's certainly not
easy you know to live and reject
temptation but allow let us allow you to
speak through us so that we can let you
fight for us in the long run in Jesus
name I pray amen
amen amen thank you so much sister Carla
um many thanks to all of you that
participated Elder ski uh thank you for
your time sister Chelsea Jack thank you
for asking those questions and adding
commentary brother Jonathan thank you
for recording and producing the video
sister Carla thank you for that closing
prayer to all of you that have asked you
know posed your questions many blessings
to you I know we have some viewers on
YouTube from all over let me see if I
can mention some oh Elder Baxter thank
you always for joining brother aim
Charles good to have you on sister pan
sister Anna altino thank you so much uh
brother Sherlock Cromwell there was also
somebody watching from yes Barbados
sister Loretta mayor thank you for
joining and ride Virginia thank you for
your presence shaa Abram and we have
persons on Zoom as well brother Kevin
Gomez as always thank you for your
support um I see here sister cariss God
bless sister Kacey Ames all the way from
Guyana I think I had also seen brother
Frank thank you brother Rose Sister Rose
pedal Tim hayan thank you for your
presence sister Cassandra James brother
Kelly who asks the questions and all of
you that are here Express many thanks to
you all and I pray that as we move um
out of this Q&A session that is s Carla
pray that we would apply the gems that
we have taken um to our lives now I
would just like to invite all of you to
join us again by God's grace Sabbath May
28th for another Q&A with elder Randy
ski but this time on the humanity of
Christ this month we spoke about the
Divinity of Christ next month we will be
speaking about the humanity of Christ it
is the same Zoom links um same YouTube
channel Facebook whether on my personal
profile or the word inspired page it
also on Twitter at the word inspired and
on Twitch atth word inspired so we hope
to see you there Sabbath May 28th at
2:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time feel
free to take a screenshot of this so
that you can keep the date in your
calendar and distribute the
flyer um many thanks as well to my
mother for her prayers and support and I
just say thank you all may we be ready
for the coming of our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ God bless and have a
wonderful rest of the Sabbath